foreign
people all over the world wherever you
are I know it's a tough one I'm an old
dude I've been around for years I live
with the right optimism but to all you
guys all your youngsters who feel
thwarted and put down and hopeless
believe me one thing all my life when I
was a little boy I dreamed of where I am
now I may have had the vision I don't
know didn't have much hope everything
happened for me and now I believe
that we can condense time we can put it
to ourselves it's not about the future
oh I'm gonna do something next year
doesn't exist tomorrow doesn't exist
next hour does not exist it's all
potential and what we can do is drag V
time into the present now enter for
solar taxes for our soul none of the
ditches whatever you want to do believe
it believe it believe it even if you
don't believe play the game got belief
act as if you believe that is power
that is sheer power and it will happen
believe you me no fool like me it's
worth in my life it will work in yours
so never give up bleep bleep bleep
I don't care if you're atheists
diagnostic or anything believe believe
for 10 more amazing rules from Anthony
Hopkins check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there life's so
short and such glorious
images in the world and such horror as
well but I want to see it all I know
people who live in the past they just
live Australia all the time talking
about something that happens to them 30
years ago